[Musique]
martin biron michel david alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir
alors je vous montre la carte rapidement
trois villes sur pause dès 20h ce soir
gatineau québec lévis et avec le nombre
de cas en outaouais ceux qui ont manqué
la carte au tout début donc 126 en
outaouais augmentation capitaine
nationale à québec de 194 à 261
bas-saint-laurent 59
chaudière-appalaches 86 vous allez me
dise pas des gros chiffres
mais la crainte ce qu'on appelait dès
hier la crainte c'est que ça devient
exponentielle et que le furent repartent
à partir de ces endroits là avec les
nouveaux variants itou martin ça a été
dur aujourd'hui jo faire entendre
d'abord l'opposition monsieur legault
qui répond la chef de l'opposition
officielle ensuite les autres partis on
a fait on a eu un tir groupé j'aime pas
cette expression de moitié le groupe et
l'opposition mais là aujourd'hui
ils ont dit incohérences improvisation
alors je rouge atteindre là dessus mais
d'abord on écoute mardi matin dans la
presse le docteur arruda souligne la
hausse des cas mais nous dit que c'était
en quelque sorte planifié 48 heures plus
tard
volte-face monsieur le président
pourtant tous les voyants étaient au
rouge depuis plusieurs jours déjà que
s'est il passé
pourquoi est ce que le premier ministre
a pas pris part et la population
quand même spécial d'entendre la chef de
l'opposition officielle la semaine
dernière elle demandait plus
d'assouplissement cette semaine 10 qui
est trop d'assouplissement la réalité
mais ce président c'est coco des
derniers jours il ya eu une explosion
corps dans quatre régions du québec on a
pris des décisions fortes rapidement
beaucoup plus rapidement que ce qui
s'est fait dans d'autres provinces ou
d'andon compétences d'autres états dans
l'ombre
comment les gens sont censés adhérer aux
mesures si le discours virevoltent comme
une feuille au vent le gouvernement a
péché par excès d'optimisme
il avait des lunettes roses les
québécois ont adhéré à ce message
et maintenant on en paye tous le prix
donc l'opposition carrément martin 17
votes faut il et ils ont pas tout à fait
tort en fait jamais que les parties de
pouce y était assez de bonne humeur
aujourd'hui se faisait longtemps qu'ils
avaient pas eu autant de munitions dans
leurs mains le gouvernement est quand
même assez fort en communication pendant
cette pandémie l'homme et la semaine
dernière a été assez difficile dans
généralement on essaie de garder une
marge de manoeuvre en communication
politique
on essaie aussi garder les attentes
basse et de préparer les consciences
quelque chose et c'est pas ce qui est
arrivé
monsieur legault si fier à une seule
donnée c'est à dire les hospitalisations
qui se tenait ce maintenant en boîtes de
500 pour dire que ça a laissé assez bien
iliad est confiné passablement dans la
dernière semaine en zone rouge à telle
enseigne qu'en zone rouge et en zone
orange
c'était plus tellement clair la
différence alors dans la tête des gens
on s'est dit mais c'est fini et les gens
peut-être des conflits nés davantage
l'épiphanie est venu mardi après le
point de presse quand on a vu que les
cas à québec notamment à la presse
malheureusement point après point de
presse est là monsieur legault a pris
les choses en main une heure ou deux
après le point de presse je parle avec
des gens autour de monsieur legault et
là on n'était plus du tout dans la même
dynamique du point de presse il fallait
que les choses changent à cette décharge
monsieur legault quand même agi
rapidement à celle d'hier qui a fait
sombrer une presse se confiner mercredi
s'il avait laissé passer pas que ça
éclate ici même chez david alec
castonguay
est-ce que l'épiphanie dont parle mme
martin elle n'aurait pas pu arriver
avant parce que les chiffres n'étaient
pas sur sa table avant où elle aurait pu
arriver à 20 c'est ça la question bien
david improvisé oui parce que je vous
dirais que gouvernement et provis depuis
le début de la pandémie et ça on peut
pas lui reprocher le comportement du
virus est imprévisible et
à partir de ce moment-là gouvernement et
est forcé de s'ajuster maintenant dans
la communication qui est un des éléments
essentiels de la gestion de la crise il
ya une condition fondamentale c'est la
cohérence et la avec un virage aussi
serré que celui là la cohérence a
disparu est ce qu'il y aurait pu
prévoir ça davantage je pense que oui
dans la mesure où ça faisait plusieurs
semaines qu'on nous disait on s'attend à
ce que ça explose alors ils peuvent pas
se dire surpris qu'il ya eu une
explosion
il l'avait peut-être pas prévu ce jour
là mais je pense que monsieur legault a
voulu et je peux le comprendre
donner un peu d'oxygène aux gens ils
étaient certainement sous pression de la
part des milieux d'affaires des
commerçants particuliers mais lui c'est
lui qui a utilement et responsables de
résister ou deux qui a ces oppressions
et cette fois si vous êtes trop résister
il n'a pas à cyril n'a pas assez
résistantes ont pardonné mais il est le
chant des sirènes étaient trop forts
haïtien il s'est lancé avec qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais le champ à le
chant des sirènes étaient forts et les
venues de partout il est des
restaurateurs du milieu de la culture
des salles de spectacles des salles de
cinéma et des élus qui disait faut que
mes région passe en zone jaune même pas
en orange me souviens du bas saint
laurent on disait faut qu'on soit en
zone jaune a semé quelques semaines
parce que les causes sont bas donc on
avait énormément de pression sur le
gouvernement parce que les chiffres
étaient bons et l'autre donné que le
gouvernement regarde beaucoup que nous
on analyse un petit peu moins que les
données sur la santé mentale
elle va très mal la santé mentale depuis
déjà un mois des québécois la violence
conjugale augmente les codes des
pressions les tentatives de suicide et
soient ils les suivent aliéné spéculons
des sondages quotidiens le succès à
porter à horacio arruda
et ça ça les inquiète est passablement
il n'y avait pas de justification avec
les cas qui étaient très bas de garder
une ville avis très très serré avec un
couvre feu à 20h avec tout le monde en
zone rouge mais on a quand même tout
ceci dit on a quand même je pense manqué
de prudence dans le vocabulaire qu'on a
utilisé qu'à la semaine passée françois
legault dit on résiste à la troisième
vague
j'ai entendu ça et je me suis dit c'est
clair qu'il va devoir se dédire dans
quelques jours parce qu'on n'est pas une
île au québec l'ontario la colombie
britannique
on est allé je pense un peu plus
sérieusement les chiffres du québec
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment avec l'agent
voir poser la même question à vous trois
parce que d'aller
dans les faits aujourd'hui quand on
regarde le présent pas l'avenir pas ce
qui risque d'arriver le présent c'est
vrai que le québec résiste encore avec
les hospitalisations à 487 le taux de
positivité je suis devient extrêmement
fatigué avec soin mais trois pour ça il
est bas en france il est à neuf dont le
but britannique il est à 8
en ontario il est à 7 c'est vrai qu
objectivement résident chauffe comme dit
michel david on n'est pas comme le dit
on n'est pas une île martin et c'est là
où la prudence peut-être aurait voulu
dire c'est un temps pas c'est vrai qu'on
résiste mais on ne sait jamais ce qui va
arriver mais on résiste mais n'en voyons
soyons prudents d'ascq on dit parce que
aujourd'hui bon à québec on voit que ça
c'est quand même enflammé le mémo rien
ça monte l'estrie l'oeil on a doublé le
nombre de cas alors et les variants
se sont ils sont pas sur le monde mais
presque alors la contamination quand
c'est parti ça va très vite moi je
serais pas étonné qu'à montréal laval la
semaine prochaine on commence à être un
peu plus inquiet les soins intensifs où
c'est les gens qui sont aux soins
intensifs sont hospitalisés beaucoup
plus longtemps ça ça veut dire du
délestage vous et des gens que tu peux
pas mettre là que tu peux pas opérer d
opération à coeur ouvert que tu peux pas
envoyer aux soins intensifs
alors il ya des facteurs qui l'a la
troisième vague ça change la dynamique
puis il faut pas juste se fier aux
hospitalisations ou sont aux nombres
absolus
non effectivement mais sauf que c'est le
signe là ce qu'on craint c'est que ça
remonte les hospitalisations comme vous
êtes il soins intensifs qui accueille
déjà un peu plus jeunes qui restent plus
longtemps c'est compliqué alors michel
david et et alec aux finitions cette
boucle
vous êtes il aurait peut-être jean début
de semaine lundi mardi 9 est plus
prudent de se garder de se garder dans
sa poche arrière une carte prudence
j'ai ouï oui parce que d'abord monsieur
legault a déjà fait l'expérience le
virage avait été moins serrés que cette
fois ci mais souvenez vous avant noël
quand il nous avait proposé le contrat
moral il a annulé au bout d'une semaine
là il l'appelle au bout de deux jours
c'est mail à deux on sait depuis la
deuxième vague que ça se passera pas de
la même façon que la première la
première était relativement plus facile
à gérer
j'accepte les ch à celle de l'homicide
est largement concentrée à montréal mais
à partir de la deuxième on a vu que
l'épidémiologie avait changé et la
société un peu partout alors et c'est
pas parce que ça va bien dans une région
que ça va bien aller la semaine
prochaine et soeurs on aurait dû s'en
souvenir
bon ce compliqué la vie de françois
legault c'est moi la conférence de
presse dont je vous parlais où on était
en manque un peu de prudence sur le fait
qu'on résiste à la troisième vague de la
semaine dernière il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses en une semaine et je
pense que françois legault avait déjà
commencé à évoluer dans sa pensée au
cours de la semaine ce qui est vraiment
plombé le gouvernement je pense celle
entrevue d'horatio à roudet la presse le
ludique est paru mardi matin qui dit
faux pas paniqué on peut monter jusqu'à
2015 tant que les hospitalisations bouge
pas c'est presque planifié tout est sous
contrôle
ça sort mardi matin puis le mercredi on
retombera confinement dans plusieurs
régions et là moi je suis un peu surpris
un an après le début de la pandémie
qu'en termes de communication politique
autant la santé publique que chez
certaines personnes au gouvernement on a
encore la difficulté à calibrer le
message ensemble en sachant que ça peut
changer très rapidement au début de la
première vague environ connaît pas le
virus mais la lah en 24 heures car le
directeur national de la santé publique
fait une sortie comme celle là pour ac
tempéré le collège des médecins qui est
quand même pas la gagne les plus
illuminés en ville il y a quand même là
quelque chose il souffrait ok je vous
garde et pour un téléjournal on va
continuer alors mais ce qu'il dit ce
sont les hospitalisations à la presse
mardi à 20h lundi publié mardi
marieront mardi au point de presse oui
non mais je vais je vais l'aider
il le dit depuis le début et on le dit
depuis le tout début
le nombre de cas la limite ses
accessoires c'est le nombre
d'hospitalisations combien de gens ont
besoin de soins médicaux puis ça fait du
délestage ça fait des ravages
parce que s'il y avait eu une éternité
puis beaucoup beaucoup de place à la
limite on a répond au temps confinés
alors qu'ils disent à mardi ce point
tenant ce qui est étonnant c'est que
deux jours après ça tienne plus mais
même mardi dire que bon c'est pas grave
c'est 2000 cas vu que les olé on le sait
aussi depuis le début que les
hospitalisations vont venir un peu plus
tard alors que les cas augmentent
inévitablement ça va finir par ce très
vieux parler aux hospitalisations
oui si la vaccination placer la fameuse
guerre
oui deux vitesses entre la vaccination
et les variants chasser l'eau point tour
de table sur la vaccination quelle est
votre analyse de l'état des choses
actuellement martin mal on vient de dire
que monsieur legault a gaffé en
confinant pas assez rapidement on voit
le féliciter sur la campagne de
vaccination parce que à date ça va très
bien je pense que c'est au québec que ça
va le lui au pays et la décision de
mardi le d'envoyer des doses aussi dans
les régions où c'est plus difficile
ben on s'est rendu compte que
il pouvait être flexible quand c'était
le temps et je pense que sur le terrain
si apprécié ouais michel david
bah oui au québec ça va très bien si on
compare par exemple à l'ontario ou de
toute évidence ça va pas mal moins bien
et où monsieur ford écoutez je suis pas
sur le terrain des vaches en ontario
mais je serais très surpris qu'il y ait
eu moins de deux vaccins toutes
proportions gardées de la population qui
a été envoyé en ontario et au québec
on commence à sec en ontario on a ce
problème de distribution et que au
québec ont le poids c'est normal et on
voit là que dans certaines régions où le
problème est moins est moins aigu on
transfère des vaccins dans les régions
ne sont plus alors inévitablement ça
crée une espèce de déséquilibre régional
mais au québec on le réalise assez
harmonieusement alors qu'en ontario
savons ib avec justement allons-y en
ontario tout de suite là aujourd'hui
ford qui met un coup de frein
généralisée ils ont en europe
désormais les mesures les plus sévères
au canada parce que là ça flambe et les
cov lab et les hospitalisations flamme
clairement allait clairement oui et
contrairement à françois legault qu'on
peut bien voir critiqué pour avoir
effectivement eu une hésitation de 48
heures d'oxford intervient deux ou trois
semaines trop tard sa troisième vague
allait commencer des jeux depuis un
petit moment tous ces experts le disent
et au moment où il la ire confine
l'ontario ses soins intensifs déborde
ou presque or il ya un délai michel
david le dit tout à l'heure il ya un
délai de deux semaines à peu près entre
l'école les hospitalisations
ça veut dire qu'on a encore une
situation qui va s'aggraver en ontario
dans les prochaines semaines il est très
très tard je pense qu'on s'est un peu
mis la tête dans le sable en ontario ça
fait un bon petit moment qu'on aurait dû
être un peu plus sévère puis l'on se
retrouve à être à gérer vraiment là la
dernière dernière minute des coques on
aurait pu certainement évité il ya déjà
deux trois semaines en l'état au dessus
de 2000 cas depuis plus d'une presque
une dizaine de jours aujourd'hui dario
l'alhambra c'est pas parce que les
médecins la bonne ne l'ont pas demandé
non pas exiger des mesures plus sévères
sean avery
depuis le début de la pandémie moi je
trouve que monsieur x 2 ensembles de
plus sensibles aux pressions économiques
on a dit que monsieur lavaud avait cédé
mais en ontario ça il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été beaucoup moins
confiné depuis le début de la pandémie
et on voit là il n'y a pas eu de
couvre-feu par exemple en ontario et on
voit là que monsieur monsieur ford et je
le redis plus tous les ontariens en paye
le prix
oui martin je pense quelle sortie de
crise va avoir un prix politique
beaucoup plus élevé que la première
vague essentiellement parce qu'on a plus
d'expérience et qu' il ya une lumière là
on commence à voir clair c'est vrai que
monsieur ford est en retard on voit
aussi en alberta que monsieur clown et
en paye le prix
monsieur faure deux agitateurs et son
confinement n'est pas un confinement
complet il ya des commerces sont encore
ouverts les écoles sont encore ouvertes
ça s'est passé pas gagné puis bon il n'y
a pas de couvre-feu il résiste au
couvre-feu et son pari pas gagné puis
effectivement les soins intensifs c'est
le double de ce qu'on a au québec
voilà ça monte ça monte bombay joyeuses
pâques où on est encore là dedans
la seule différence je le dis avec notre
ami sébastien tout à l'heure c'est qu'on
a quand même des vaccins mais s'il
monsieur legault avait eu comme 10 15%
de plus de vacciner peut-être qu'il
aurait pu faire ce qu'il a fait en début
de semaine et qui marquaient un petit un
petit état de vaccination à suivre merci
beaucoup c'est toujours apprécié merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
non